den ganzen vormittag über berichten wir
heute von den straßen berlins denn da
ist zurzeit der teufel los die
autofahrer sind auf der zinne wahl
klimaaktivisten den verkehr lahmlegen
pendler konnten nicht zur arbeit
notärzte nicht zu ihren patienten
spielen sich wirklich chaotische szenen
ab
[Musik]
stau stress streit und stumpf schon
wieder legen aktivisten von letzte
generation den straßenverkehr in der
bundeshauptstadt laden die klima
demonstranten sitzen auf der straße
blockieren ampel in die kreuzung ihre
hände kleben einige mit sekundenkleber
an den asphalt
kein durchkommen durch menschen kennen
auch für diesen smart fahrerin eine
ärztin die zu einer op muss alles
betteln endlich vorbei zu können hilft
nichts autofahrer stinksauer sie machen
ihrem ärger luft ziehen die menschen von
der straße erst dann kann das mal
passieren
an einer anderen blockade verliert ein
autofahrer völlig
chaotische szenen und die frage ist ja
wer ist der auslöser gehen die aktion
der aktivisten zu weit dies ja auch in
anderen städten gibt was halten die
menschen vom krawall auf der straße wir
haben uns in bochum um gehört hier
spricht das volk
[Musik]
ein no go also ich würde sowas überhaupt
nicht unterstützen klima klar aber sowas
garnicht auf gar keinen fall das muss
auf jeden fall immer so ein bisschen
gesittet bleiben das geht zu weit das
dürfen die nicht machen das ist
behinderung von amtsträgern zum beispiel
feuerwehr und rettungssanitäter das geht
zu weit man kann das anders
bewerkstelligen da muss man nicht den
ganzen verkehr blockieren und vor allen
dingen auch nicht menschen leben in also
menschenleben in gefahr bringen das geht
soweit
ich sag mal so die alle die straßen
blockieren da trifft dann lassen sie ihr
auto weiterlaufen das verbraucht aber
wahrscheinlich mehr an abgrasen als
alles andere ich meine klimaprozess dem
allgemein finde ich ist in ordnung also
muss sein sollte sein wird sich zu wenig
darum gekümmert und da ich mein okay man
darf mit fliege ich andere sache nicht
einschränken also not abzuwarten
britischen durchkommen die polizei dort
täglich kommen abschleppwagen und durch
um also das geht zu weit
alles andere finde ich allerdings
richtig also ich muss viel mehr gemacht
werden für den klimaschutz ich denke ich
würde wahrscheinlich genauso reagieren
weil wenn du weißt dass ich so und so
viele stunden gearbeitet hast und du
willst einfach nur zu hause ankommen und
es geht dann nicht voran wird man schon
denke ich mal sich ne jetzt dadurch
müsste und werde sehr dringend da würde
ich auch mal fragen was ist euch nicht
in ordnung ich möchte hier gerne durch
und zur not muss man die 110 rufen dann
wollen selber hand anlegen sollte man ja
erstmal nicht machen ich war nicht auto
deswegen will ich da vielleicht auch ein
bisschen geprägt sondern ich würde immer
der fahrradfahrer genervt ist das die
autos beim luft verpesten mehr oder
weniger aber klar ich wäre
wahrscheinlich auch so ich bin sehr
komplexe generell deswegen wäre ich
wahrscheinlich erst ruhig aber ich
verstehe dass solche genervt sind
vereinigen sie dann wichtige termine
verpassen und das ja auch über die frage
was für eine art von protest bringt was
und was macht heute nur sauer also ja
ich kann die emotionen verstehen ja wie
wird sich die situation heute weiter
entwickeln wir sind den ganzen vormittag
vor ort und berichten natürlich live
versprechen mit genervten autofahrern
und auch rechtsexperten
und wir sprechen jetzt mit marcel score
von der auch dabei war als die straßen
durch demonstranten blockiert wurden er
hat selbst aktivisten von der straße
gezogen herr skowron scheinen sie doch
mal wie war die situation vor ort
also eigentlich war die situation man
kann man statt einer roten ampel
gekommen man hat das erst gar nicht
bemerkt man hat die leute zwei riskiert
die an oracle stangen aber dann als die
apple prüft oder sind die leute dann
rüber gelaufen und haben sich auf einen
meiner linie gestellt man dachte nicht
jetzt schon wieder und dann standen sie
mit den bannern dann sagt mir gut
schauen wir mal ob die jetzt beginnen
oder
stehen bleiben wenn ein anderer geräumt
und dann gesagt kann die situationen die
haben das auto angefasst sich
dagegengelehnt
und dann kam auch gleich einer ich soll
mich beruhigen noch nicht ausgestiegen
ist habe ich dann ist mir dann die
schüler ja gesagt jetzt reicht's jetzt
also große gleich eine minute später
gleich wieder ausgestiegen und dann rum
hat damit den um diskutiert und als das
nicht so übergaben häuser akut
inwiefern konnte man mit den aktivisten
denn reden
ja die die sitzen hatte ich dafür die
die konnten gar nichts gibt immer sagen
die saßen konnten sich zusammen und
einfach nur nicht weg so schwer machen
da gab es dann so drei leute die
dahinter her zwischen den leuten hin und
hergelaufen haben und dann versucht
haben zu reden und zu erklären
dass erklären völlig daneben war also
man hat nichts mehr verstanden und dann
kam auch schon die anderen dazu lkw
fahrer sei ausgestiegen
der fahrer ausgestiegen also dann war da
also dann war alles gelaufen
die diskussionen die dann da waren ja
die verführten dazu nicht
warum macht sie das verhalten so wütend
mussten sie sich sehr zurückhaltend und
was hätten sie am besten mit denen
gemacht
gar nichts also ich bin
natürlich überglücklich ist er
beschreibt war ich bin ein sehr ruhiger
mensch also sehr entspannt
aber es gibt also gute wo dann auch
mit jugend platz und wenn ich dann höre
warum dieser sitzen und sich dann nicht
vernünftig erklären können und
die essens verschwendung ist ja kein
neues thema aber den zusammenhang das
nicht zu finden die leute verstehen es
nicht die sehens nicht sie sehen
verstehen die banner nicht
man kriegt keine formation man wird
nicht aufgeklärt und die leute müssen ja
eigentlich diese bevölkerung die
arbeiter de die mama papa ist sich alle
zu hause sitzen die müssen hier auf ihre
seite kriegen und die machen die ganze
aktion eigentlich zunichte weil sie
stehen jetzt im vordergrund die
aktivisten auch keiner besserung
ich denke sie der ansatz ist völlig
falsch und
das macht mich als sauer das halt das
thema was eigentlich wichtig ist
natürlich untergrund verbessert wird
sagte marcel sollmann der selbst
aktivisten von der straße weg getragen
hat da ist die frage darf man das
eigentlich zugeschaltet ist uns jetzt
uwe lehnert er ist anwalt für verkehrs
und strafrecht guten morgen herr lennart
die frage wo mache ich mich strafbar
wenn ich aktivisten von der straße weg
tragen
das kommt darauf an wie also
grundsätzlich gibt es in deutschland das
recht der versammlungsfreiheit artikel 8
grundgesetz ist eigentlich geschützt
wenn sie da jetzt
nicht genehmigt ist das seine sache oder
wenn die polizei jetzt eine eine art
letzte das wir gründen werden soll aber
wie air berlin gehen dann könnte sie das
sanft und leise machen und nötigung sein
also würden sie ja sagen geh mal zur
seite und wird eventuell zeit
geschrieben wenn sie allerdings jetzt in
einem hans de oder
im boxen um den der zeitung das ist
natürlich eine körperverletzung also so
oder so würde ich davon lassen aber
nötigung wenn ich wirklich nur hingehe
und man kann diese wut ja auch zum teil
wirklich nachvollziehen ja ich will zur
arbeit hat einen wichtigen termin oder
ich bin vielleicht sogar arzt und geht
dort hin und sag einfach gehen sie jetzt
zur seite
das nicht ein bisschen mehr als wenn sie
der serien oder bitte das gericht alle
bitte einzige sprechen mit denen das ist
nötigung ist wenn sie jetzt auch stehen
oder wenn sie jetzt den halb drücken da
steht jetzt fragen sagen sie ihn jemals
so zur seite das wäre dann müsste man
eine gewisse psychische gewalt ausüben
um nötigung also nach körperkontakt muss
dann da schon besteht für was passiert
denn überhaupt den demonstranten wenn
sie den verkehr so lahmlegen erst wurde
gesagt nichts weil das der
versammlungsfreiheit unterliegt aber da
bin ich ständig polizei kommen und dann
entsprechende verfügung erlassen
und ein quadrat ums geld aufgebrummt
werden und wenn die aber die autofahrer
daran hindern weiter zu fahren das ist
ihrerseits nötigung immer dann wenn aber
dann müssten sie diese verfügung
erlassen worden sein und wenn sie
natürlich die polizei versucht die welt
zu tragen und sie so wie wir beide
wörter nacht steigt das wäre dann
widerstand gegen vollstreckungsbeamte
und da kann es geldstrafen bis zur
freiheitsstrafe geben der cdu-politiker
frank balzer hat sich dafür
ausgesprochen solche aktivisten gleich
dem haftrichter vorzuführen
würde es zu so einem fall überhaupt
jemals kommen können nein das sind ja
eine sachlichere wenn wenn wenn
untersuchung sagt droht also es ist es
somit sei das rindvieh ladendiebstahl
begehen weil sie auch nicht es sei denn
es ist der 150 also wenn ich das wenn
die anschläge vor strafrichter wie
gesagt immer nur dann brot oder dann
muss die stadt an alte vertragen das
acht gelassen wird und der wird dann vom
vom haftrichter lassen aber das so weit
über glauben noch nicht dass
sind live-bilder aus berlin-tegel meine
damen und herren wo klimaaktivisten
in diesem moment den verkehr lahmlegen
wir haben es gucken der genervten
autofahrer es kam auch in den
vergangenen tagen schon zu chaotischen
szenen
[Musik]
prügeleien zwischen autofahrern und
demonstranten autofahrer die versuchten
die demonstranten wegzutragen es kannten
notärzte im stau die nicht zu
operationen konnten ja und auch heute
wieder diese bilder man fragt sich
wirklich warum immer wieder wir hatten
auch szenen wo sich die aktivisten mit
sekundenkleber tatsächlich an die straße
geklebt haben damit sie nicht
weggetragen werden können das sieht hier
nicht danach aus aber dennoch wir machen
kein platt wie lassen die autofahrer
nicht vorbeifahren
und es gibt natürlich ein konzert und
die menschen verlieren so langsam die
näher
mittendrin ist unser reporter peter
wicke der jetzt hier ins bild kommt
täter übernimmt bitte
[Musik]
thomas service konnte ein wenig
verstehen ist es sehr laut hier seit
rund 5 nun läuft jetzt eben diese
blockade straße wie sie den ganzen
morgen schon mit den aktivisten
unterwegs hier in berlin ist
die nicht funktioniert weil die polizei
heute wird mit einem großen aufgebot in
der stadt unterwegs sei eigentlich alle
kreuzungen kontrolliert hat und es den
aktivisten deswegen erst nicht gelungen
ist jetzt doch schon die straßen zu
blockieren
sie haben sich eben wieder hingesetzt
und gesehen es hat sich schon jetzt nach
wenigen minuten ein sehr langer stau
gebildet und die menschen sind
tatsächlich sehr wütend sind die ersten
schon angekommen haben die aktivisten
nebenan geschrieben dass sie doch bitte
jetzt umsonst weil man zu arbeiten ist
weil man termine hat wir können einmal
hier mit einem merkel
warum sie das eigentlich machen
keine frage warum setzt ihr euch hier
auf die straße setzen uns hier auf die
straße weil unsere gesellschaft auf den
klimakollaps zu gast und den wenigen
jahrzehnten auch in deutschland hungern
müssen wenn wir die klimakatastrophe
nicht aufhalten und warum setzt ihr euch
dann auf die straße und blockiert
aber jetzt jetzt geht man sich hier an
die straße fest mit sekundenkleber genau
anschauen wie das passiert sei
bisher
wie man einfach
auf die hand geklebt und dann
[Musik]
auf den asphalt
und da ist auch das wird schon das erste
hinweisschild rausgeholt stopp angeklebt
damit man sozusagen bescheid weiß uns
nicht die hand gewaltsam losreißt denn
das könnte
sehr schmerzhaft werden wir haben es
gerade gehört
warum man hier auf der straße ist
begrüßen eine klimakatastrophe
es bleibt trotzdem die frage ob das ein
legitimer weg ist ebenso zu
demonstrieren was das bringen sollen
hier die handarbeiten menschen
der arbeit zu kommen was die dafür
können und ob es eigentlich auch der
richtige weg ist eben sich maßnahmen so
zu erpressen indem man solchen kunden
sie sagt sie wissen sind eben auch genau
die aktivisten
die bereits im sommer vom bundestag
gesessen haben und
hungerstreiks durchgeführt haben olaf
scholz mit ihnen gesprochen hat wollen
sie uns was dazu sagen
was halten sie davon dass die hacker von
halten ganz ehrlich diese absolute
scheiße sie sollen bei den politikern
hochgehen und nicht hier uns und wir
haben alle zu tun sie machen ihren job
ich mache meinen job und was machen die
stören dabei es reicht wir können
zufrieden sein dass ich jetzt ein
schöner effekt habe dass sich entspannt
bin ich schon nach vorne ja
müssen sie heute noch hin was haben sie
noch vor wo man die menschen sehr gerade
meine arbeit ich muss auch geld
verdienen wie jeder andere deutsche
bürger ja alle müssen wir unser geld
verdienen was machen die hindern uns
daran soll nicht in ordnung
wir haben es gehört die wut der frust
ist hier ja ehrlicherweise durchaus
verständlich sehr hoch das verständnis
für diesen weg so auf den auf den die
notwendigkeit von klimaschutz
hinzuweisen ist hier tatsächlich nicht
wagen wir können mal schauen wie weit
die schlange eben gerade schon ist wir
sehen eben da oben läuft die
stadtautobahn die berliner stadtautobahn
lang das ist die a100 wirklich eine der
verkehrsadern in der stadt und die
taktik sozusagen der aktivisten ist es
jetzt die ausfahrt hier zu blockieren
und dadurch ein rückstau bis auf die
autobahn zu provozieren wodurch eben die
ganze autobahn am ende dann lahmgelegt
werden könnte oder
müsste er nicht hier eingetroffen peter
wir sind sehr viele reporter kollegen
von dir wir sehen allerdings keine
einsatzkräfte wir sehen nicht die
polizei wie geht das jetzt weiter wird
die polizei das gleich auflösen wo sind
die beamten
ab jetzt gerade da vorne kommt die
polizei genau in dem moment wo du es
angesprochen hast anderer die werden
jetzt zumindest kennen wir so aus den
letzten tagen hier erstmal anschauen
weil sie die große problematik ist
natürlich dass sich die aktivisten wie
wir es gerade gesehen haben live gesehen
haben bereits festgelegt haben wir
können gleich mal vorne hin dann werden
wir uns das jetzt anschauen was die
polizei macht die größe das große
problem ist dass sie sich festgeklebt
haben und dass man die demonstranten die
aktivisten die blockierer sozusagen
erstmal von der straße los lösen muss
und das ist durchaus schwierig
dann kommen dann
verschiedene substanzen zum einsatz um
das sozusagen möglichst schmerzlos zu
machen aber das ist natürlich auch die
klare taktik der aktivisten um das
sozusagen möglichst lang in die länge zu
ziehen durch dieses festkleben wir sehen
jetzt die einsatzkräfte kommen hier
gerade an werden jetzt erst mal kontakt
aufnehmen zu den aktivisten und
dann wird man möglichst schnell
versuchen diese menschen hier von der
straße holen damit dass hier weiter
gehen kann denn wie ich bereits erwähnt
habe dass es eine der hauptverkehrsadern
der stadt und wenn die lahmgelegt ist
ist das mehr als problematisch die
berliner bürgermeisterin
franziska giffey hat sich auch gestern
schon dazu geäußert hat klar gesagt dass
das hier eine grenzüberschreitung ist
dass das anliegen er durchaus berechtigt
ist aber dass man hier eine klare grenze
überschreitet und dass man das doch
bitte sein lassen soll wir hören jetzt
immer mehr sie reden von dort vorne
kommen auch weitere polizeikräfte
hätten sie haben heute morgen ab juli
mit seinem anwalt gesprochen schon mit
einem verkehrsanwalt über die situation
wenn diese proteste angemeldet sind dann
kann man eigentlich nicht viel dagegen
tun hat er uns gesagt
ja
bin selber kein anwalt ich weiß aber
nicht ob es ob man eine straßenblockade
anmelden kann man kann protestzüge
anmelden man kann anmelden wo man
langlaufen möchte man kann aber nicht
und diese proteste sind auch nicht
angemeldet man kann nicht unangemeldet
einfach eine straße blockieren und
gezielt wirklich versuchen den verkehr
lahm zu legen da wird ja auch immer
darauf geachtet ist wenn demonstration
angekündigt werden dass die möglichst so
verlaufen wie möglich so durchgeführt
werden dass damit der verkehr eben nicht
behindert wird hier ist aber eben das
klare ziel den verkehr zu behindern und
wir können vielleicht auch noch einmal
mit dem arzt sprechen gerade die
kollegen mit dem herrn können ihn gleich
noch einmal ansprechen kann der einen
der polizisten fragen wie es da jetzt
weitergeht
[Musik]
das können gleich einmal machen nur eine
anmerkung noch wir haben es jetzt gerade
gesehen wie der eine hersteller etwas
forscher geworden ist er hat gesagt er
hätte jetzt zum glück noch nicht
eingegriffen und sie selber weggetragen
wird auch dringend von abgeraten dass
bürger hier selber tätig werden und die
menschen von der straße ziehen denn dann
geht es schnell auch in die richtung der
körperverletzung wenn man dort zum
fahrstuhl geht das haben wir alles in
den letzten tagen schon erlebt ich weiß
nicht ob wir mit dem polizisten sprechen
können dass es meistens schwierig kann
einmal in den entschuldigung können sie
mir sagen was was passiert jetzt werde
ich erstmal gucken ja wie ist denn deine
einschätzung zu der lager man würde ja
jetzt meint die polizei kommt in einem
wahnsinnigen wahnsinnigen tempo
angereist mit viel sirene und jetzt
stehen die beamten da aber erstmal und
gucken sich die lage an man hätte
erwartet dass die polizisten sofort
anfangen auch die straße zu räumen
gut die menschen sind ja hier schon
bereits festgeklebt ist die hand fest
geklickt und
[Musik]
haben sie sich in den letzten tagen
schon mal an berliner straßenfeste klebt
tut das weh warum machen sie also wir
machen das weil wir ja so natürlich noch
länger sitzen bleiben können und noch
mehr aufmerksamkeit auf unsere forderung
unsere forderungen nämlich das essen
retten gesetz und eine agrarwende
jahr 2030
darauf mehr fokus zu legen das tut in
den meisten also jetzt tut es gerade
nicht wähle ich habe da auch in werner
betz und die polizei löst das in der
regel auch sehr sehr schnell und dann
bin ich wieder frei beziehungsweise dann
in gewahrsam
hier stehen hinter ihnen sehr viele
menschen im stau das sind menschen die
hart arbeiten müssen die termine haben
und teilweise könnten da auch sogar
krankenwagen behindert werden die
menschen in not hilfe bremst ins
krankenhaus bringen müssen jetzt sind
sie hier auf der straße feste klebt wie
rechtfertigen sie das dass sie diese
menschen und auf menschen in not
eventuell daran hindern hilfe zu
bekommen also erstmal wir haben immer
rettungsgassen lieber lassen
aber wenn sie festgeklebt sind dann
können in der mitte ist eine
rettungsgasse und die autofahrerinnen
sind immer dazu angehalten eine
rettungsgasse zu bilden sind ja nicht
alle leute bei uns angeklebt und die
anderen sachen ist betrifft uns ja alle
wenn wir in 20 30 jahren unsere
ernährung unser leben unser überleben
nicht gesichert ist was unser grundrecht
ist wenn unser stolz nicht handelt
dann ist es egal ob jemand mal einen tag
zu spät zur arbeit kam wenn wir dann
alle krepieren so
verzichte gerade auf 500 bis 1000 euro
jeden tag ich bin spreche ich bin
selbstständiger und ich mache das seit
zweieinhalb wochen ich verzichtet
komplett auf meinem lohn gut aber
glauben sie dass mit der rettungsgasse
funktioniert weil wenn wir uns das jetzt
hier einmal anschauen da keine
rettungsgasse es ist auch sehr schwierig
weil sind wenige seitenstreifen zu sehen
da eine rettungsgasse zu bilden wenn
jetzt hier jemand in einem mit einem
herzinfarkt im krankenwagen
hilfe gebracht werden muss jetzt nicht
möglich zu sein der hier im stau stehen
haben immer wieder rettungsgassen
gelassen wenn die autos das nicht machen
dann ist es wie auf einer autobahn auf
dem autobahn stau es liegt in den auch
bei den autofahrerinnen weil sie auch
gesehen haben dass sich diese
zurückgestaut aber unsere mittleren
leute können auch immer weg das heißt
wenn da ein rettungswagen ist dann
können wir jederzeit auf stehen uns
haben wir auch immer wieder gemacht und
bewiesen
[Musik]
finden sie das aber also gut das müssen
sie wissen ob sie das jetzt nicht ein
bisschen selbstgerechten dass die schuld
auf die auto also ich würde die schuld
jetzt nicht auch die autofahrer stehen
sie haben sich hier festgeklebt der
straßenverkehr sondern ist es so dass
die autofahrer innen wenn es einen stau
gibt auf eine rettungsgasse achten
außerdem machen wir es hier frei ob es
wäre längst ja auch vom thema wir sind
hier weil dessen direkten gesetz fordern
weil dir für uns selber allein leben
überleben kämpfen verstehen sie und
natürlich wollen wir kein leitprodukt
produzieren und natürlich wollen wir
niemand der in herzinfarkt im
rettungswagen hat und wir tun alles
dafür dass rettungswegen hier
durchkommen und es klappt auch immer ich
versteh ich verstehe durchaus ihr
anliegen und das hat er auch durchaus
seine rechtfertigung aber erhalten sie
das eigentlich für legitim sich
sozusagen maßnahmen zu erpressen indem
sie hier an solchen
empfindlichen punkten ansetzen dafür
gibt es eigentlich ein parlament in
deutschland halten sie es für legitim
dass unsere regierung nicht nach dem
pariser klimaabkommen handelt dass
unsere regierung rotzfrech sagt dass sie
im nächsten und im übernächsten jahr die
klimaziele nicht erreicht halten sie es
für legitim dass der ehemalige chef
berater david king zwei bis drei jahren
voraus sagt bis die klima kipp punkte
erreicht hätten und hier auf eine 1,5
grad 2 3 4
sie müssen nicht mir fragen stellen
erstellen halten sie es für legitim dass
unsere regierung nicht
handelt unser überleben was unser
grundrecht ist nicht garantiert halten
sie das für legitim ist frage ich sie
und sie sind auch journalisten sind
bürger und bürger in und deswegen fragen
sie sagen sie doch mal halten sie das
für legitim dass unsere regierung so auf
uns reagiert ich habe mich hier gerade
nicht an der straße festgeklebt deswegen
stelle ich in die frage fragen
sie wird mich nicht an der straße
festkleben und dafür gibt es alle vier
jahren wahlen wo ich dann wegen gehen
kann wenn ich mit der aktuell
grundsätzlich zufrieden
es sind viel zu geringe ziel es gab ein
bürger rat klima letztes jahr die hat
sehr sehr tolle vorschläge
vorschläge gemacht und die regierung
hält sich nicht daran das sehen sie
jetzt so der mehr
der großteil bevölkerung scheint das
anders zu sehen weil es kleben sie sich
ja nicht alle anderen der straße fest
jetzt ist eine andere frage wie finden
sie das denn eigentlich hier den ganzen
tag dann angepöbelt zu werden wenn sie
an der straße festgeklebt sind jetzt
hatte ich ein wunderschönes gespräch hat
sich 20 minuten eine frau die 20 minuten
zu spät gekommen ist zu ihrer arbeit und
zwar freiwillig hat sich daneben
gestellt hat gesagt
wenn die ganzen tag euch leute anpöbeln
weil sie vielleicht kein verständnis für
haben dann stehe ich hier mit da und
frage nach ihren gründen wir hatten am
montag eine frau ist erst einmal
gekommen mit drei kindern
erst hat das kind geweint weil es
überfordert war von der situation das
war vielleicht 45 jahre alt ist sie
zurück gegangen dann kam sie wieder und
hat gefragt nach unseren motiven und
dann haben sie ein drittes mal und das
kind selber wollte sich mit auf die
straße setzen
verstehen sie es gibt natürlich viele
wütende autofahrer energie dort sind
hier sind eingesperrt na klar ich werde
auch mit und ich habe riesen großes
verständnis dafür und es tut mir leid
für die menschen es tut mir leid wenn
jemand zu spät zur arbeit kommt
vielleicht sogar seinen job verliert
es hilft uns alles nichts wenn sie in 20
bis 30 jahren nicht ernährt werden
können wir haben ein klima notstand das
müssen auch die richter und richterinnen
akzeptieren so und deswegen sind unsere
handlungen dadurch legitimiert
okay ein interessantes verständnis
soweit hier von den demonstranten wir
können uns das hier noch einmal
abschließend anschauen das sind jetzt
wirklich mittlerweile sehr viele
polizeikräfte vor ort die auch hinten in
dem stau stehen nach wie vor in es wurde
zwar gerade behauptet es wäre eine
rettungsgasse möglich wir können uns
dass sie an sorgen hier ist auf jeden
fall keine rettungsgasse möglich wenn
hier jetzt ein krankenwagen durch müsste
würde das sehr schwierig und eventuell
lebensgefährlich sehen werden wir haben
es aber gerade demonstrant sind durchaus
bereit auch jobs von menschen zu opfern
führen gegen davon kann man halten was
man möchte ich persönlich finde dass ein
wenig selbstgerecht ja ansonsten hat die
polizei gerade auch noch eine durchsage
von sich gegeben dass man die straße
doch bitte räumen sollte aber eben die
menschen sind festgeklebt haben sich
bestens ausgerüstet mit wärmedecken mit
wärme petz um sich warm zu halten und
sind auf gar keinen fall bereit hier die
straße zu räumen ich vor ort in berlin
dort haben sich klimaaktivisten von gut
einer stunde an die straße geklebt mit
sekundenkleber und wir sehen hier wie
die polizei
versucht diese menschen wieder zu lösen
von der straße mit einer speziellen
mischung aus öl und weiteren sachen und
es ist wirklich mühselig ist es kleinst
arbeit und das alles weil die
klimaaktivisten ihre forderungen durch
bringen wollen ist es das 27 mal dass
das in den letzten tagen wochen hier bei
uns in berlin und auch in anderen
großstädten auch in österreich passiert
es bildet sich meter lange staus die wir
eben gesehen haben gut konzerte die
menschen die autofahrer die pendler
haben null verständnis dafür aber sie
müssen stehen wenn sie stehen seit
stunden im stau und kein durchkommen ist
möglich und mit ihnen peter wilke unser
reporter der live dabei ist peter
thomas wir haben es gerade gesehen es
läuft eben jetzt sozusagen die lösungs
maßnahme der demonstranten der
aktivisten hier von der straße wir haben
noch mal nachgefragt es handelt sich
darum geben um ein spezielles
lösungsmittel was angewandt wird womit
die hände eingepinselt werden insgesamt
fünf demonstranten den fünf aktivisten
sind noch an der straße festgeklebt die
polizei ist hier mit 10 bis 20 kräften
mindestens vor ort wir haben es auch
gerade beobachten können es werden jetzt
zeugen aussagen von den autofahrern
aufgenommen wir können uns da anschauen
das auto für auto wird ab gegangen da
werden die bögen hinein gereist dann
kann jeder seine zeugenaussage aufgeben
denn natürlich wird jetzt hier am ende
auch gegen die aktivisten die hier den
straßenverkehr blockieren ermittelt und
wahrscheinlich werden sie auch für den
ganzen tag heute erstmal in gewahrsam
genommen und es hat sich auch gezeigt
warum der notarzt hier ist die
polizeikräfte übernehmen ebendieses
pinseln dieses ablösen da kommen dann
auch kleine stäbchen zum einsatz mit
denen unter die hand gegangen wird um
sie dann vom stufen der straße zu lösen
und ein arzt muss dann sozusagen wenn
die hand gelöst wurde die hand abnehmen
gucken ob die person soweit
gesundheitlich in ordnung ist ob da
alles passt und dann kann eben die
polizeiliche maßnahme fortgesetzt werden
soweit hier aktuell von den berliner
straßen ein großer stau konnte wie es
bisher überblicken kann wohl vermieden
werden aber natürlich für die menschen
für die rund 30 autos die hier schon
fest sitzen ist das natürlich mehr als
ärgerlich wenn du hast ja mit den
autofahrern gesprochen auch gibt es das
verständnis für das anliegen der
klimaaktivisten oder sind sie einfach
nur wahnsinnig sauer
die sind eher wahnsinnig sauer und das
durchaus verständlich wir haben zu
erfüllen mit einem aktivisten gesprochen
die uns berichtet hat das in den letzten
tagen sich kinder zu ihnen gesellt haben
als sie sich auf die straße gesetzt
haben was auch nochmal fraglich ist
warum man denn dann auch noch kinder auf
der straße mobilisiert sich zusätzlich
auf die straße zu setzen aber hier vor
ort können wir beobachten hier hat
niemand verständnis hier sind die
menschen wirklich wütend manchmal endet
das dann auch in lauter schreierei heute
hat hier aber niemand eingegriffen hier
ist niemand heute die aktivisten
angegangen da hatten haben dass die
autofahrer die polizei machen lassen
aber wir haben mit mehreren autofahrern
gesprochen und da ist wirklich einfach
nur frust über diese nummer und so
gesagt sie hätten termine termine werden
heute verpasst man müsse arbeiten und
man solle doch bitte dass das anliegen
wäre durchaus gerechtfertigt aber man
soll es doch bitte anders
anders äußern und nicht sie hier die
vollkommen unbeteiligt sind an ihrer
arbeit hindern und ebenso in ihrem leben
behindern der eine hat uns gesagt ein
autofahrer hat er müsste jetzt heute
überstunden machen und das eben nur weil
die aktivisten weil diese menschen
glauben sie müssten sich hier an der
straße festkleben um auf ihre anliegen
aufmerksam zu machen der kleber ist
jetzt gerade beim letzten aktivisten
gelöst worden eben mit diesem speziellen
lösungsmittel und auch der stau können
wir uns anschauen ist bereinigt die
autofahrer konnten das feld hier schon
verlassen allerdings ist nach wie vor
hinten die ausfahrt wir sehen das
blaulicht gesperrt solange eben der eine
aktivistin noch auf der straße sitzt
aber es kann nur noch um minuten um
wenige minuten gehen
bis das hier alles wieder läuft das hat
jetzt insgesamt eine stunde gedauert
eine stunde klingt vielleicht erstmal
nicht so viel aber hier im berliner
berufsverkehr ist das durchaus eine
wucht und hat ebenso ganz schön viel
ärger hier vor ort gesorgt sind immer
noch sehr viele polizei geht ford jetzt
in die straße verlassen denn jetzt hat
auch der aktivist die straße verlassen
und ja sofern jetzt lässt er sich auch
noch hier wegziehen möchte also bis zum
letzten moment kämpfen dort vorne werden
dann die personalien aufgenommen von den
aktivisten und
aktuell ist nicht abzusehen ob sie dann
auch in gewahrsam genommen werden oder
nicht eine kleine anekdote kann ich noch
berichten die berliner polizei hat sich
tatsächlich sogar bei uns erkundigt wie
wir dann so schnell hier vor ort gewesen
wären denn das wäre durchaus interessant
für sie weil dann könnten sie ihn sehen
können was für ein kleber dort
angewendet wurde als sie demonstranten
als die aktivisten sich hier eben
festgeklebt haben also da läuft auch
noch ein bisschen aufarbeitung dieses
geschehens um dann demnächst vielleicht
noch schneller wenn das denn wieder
passieren sollte darauf reagieren zu
können peter du sprichst es an demnächst
du konntest auch mit klima aktivisten
sprechen gibt es da ankündigungen wird
womöglich morgen schon wieder sowas
passieren
ja also die aktivisten die ganzen
letzten tage schon und auch heute war da
eigentlich keine meinungsänderung zu
sehen sind die ganz klar unterwegs mit
der maßgabe wir werden das jetzt täglich
weiter machen wir werden jeden tag
weiter die berliner straßen die berliner
autobahnen blockieren uns festkleben und
eben für staus sorgen bis so sie fordern
dass die politik das von ihnen
gewünschte
gesetz zur lebensmittel rettung durch
setzt sie wollen eben große
supermarktketten dazu verpflichten
lebensmittel nicht wegzuschmeißen
sondern eben
zu spenden das wollen die aktivisten
unter anderem durchsetzen außerdem
wollen sie eine agrarwende zu einer
klimafreundlicheren landwirtschaft das
sind ja alles durchaus berechtigte
anliegen aber es stellt sich nach wie
vor die frage ob das denn wirklich ein
der richtige weg ist durch diese diese
blockaden hier auf den berliner straßen
das sozusagen durch zu erpressen von der
gesellschaft und von der politik
insofern ist abzuwarten wie das hier in
den nächsten tagen in berlin weiter geht
es ist auf jeden fall angekündigt dass
die blockaden weitergehen aber wir haben
es heute auch schon den ganzen tag
gemerkt die berliner polizei ist mehr
als gewarnt und reagiert auch schon
darauf und ist mit großaufgeboten in der
stadt unterwegs bewacht die kreuzungen
und konnte dafür damit auch heute schon
dafür sorgen dass die aktivisten
durchaus daran gehindert werden die
kreuzung zu blockieren peter wilke danke
für die live reportagen den ganzen
vormittag über von vor ort aus berlin
und ja wahrscheinlich dass noch bis
morgen peter